Our calendar is just a mess.
It's a very complicated mismatch
of different cycles
and different lengths of time.
And every once in a while, we
have to make an adjustment to
those lengths of time to
make things match.
And one way we do that is every
once in a while adding
an extra day to our calendar.
And that extra day
is February 29.
When we have an extra day, we
call that year a leap year.
So there are two fundamental
units of time that we use that
are tied to actual,
physical events.
One is the day, and that's the
time it takes for the Earth to
make one rotation
around its axis.
The other is the year, and
that's the time it takes the
Earth to make one revolution in
its orbit around the Sun.
Every other unit we use-- the
week, the second, the hour--
is fairly arbitrary, but those
two are tied to actual,
physical events.
In a more well-behaved universe,
our calendar would
be a lot easier to deal with
if 365 of these exactly
matched one of those.
But of course, that's not
the way it works.
Actually, our year is made up
of about 365 and 1/4 days.
That means that every time the
Earth had gone around the Sun
once, it's actually rotated
365 and 1/4 times.
If we rotate 365 and 1/4 times
every year, but we're only
counting 365 of them in a year,
that means every four
years, we've got an extra day
that hasn't appeared in our
calendar, so we have
to put it back in.
And that's where February
29 comes in.
But that's not quite enough.
The number of days
in a year is not
exactly 365 and 6 hours.
It's 365, 5 hours, 49 minutes,
and 16 seconds.
That means if we do what I just
said, by the end of 100
years, we've accumulated too
much time in our calendar, and
now we need to take
a full day away.
So every 100 years, on a year
that would've been a leap year
going by the four-year rule, we
skip one, and we take away
that extra day.
So every time the year is
divisible by 100-- that means
1900, 2000, 2100--
we skip the leap year.
And so, on those years,
February has 28
days and not 29 days.
Except that's still
not quite right.
There's an extra bit that we
need to correct again, because
now, every 400 years, we've
missed an extra day.
So now, every 400 years, we
reverse that rule, and we add
the leap year back in.
So this becomes very
complicated, but the
fundamental rule is for a given
year, if the year's
divisible by 4, then
it's a leap year.
Unless the year is divisible by
100, in which case it's not
a leap year.
Unless the year is divisible by
400, in which case it's a
leap year, and we have
February 29.
The mismatch between the
rotation of the Earth and the
revolution around the Sun is
such that that extra amount of
time is taken care of to a
fairly high precision by all
these actual corrections.
In actual fact, it still means
that we will need an extra
correction at the end of 3,200
years, but that's not actually
built into our calendar.
We stop at the end of 400 years
in these corrections.
Astronomers are used to dealing
with all sorts of not
very convenient measurement
systems.
That's, unfortunately,
the legacy of our
very historical science.
So we are used to dealing
with this.
And if we need to calculate the
number of days that have
passed between two dates, it
does become very complicated,
and you have to calculate how
many months, and how many days
in that month, and whether there
are leap years involved.
We simplify that by using our
own calendar for the passage
of time known as Julian dates,
and all that is is a single
number that counts the number
of days that have gone by
since a very distant
day in the past.
The zero point of that calendar
is Monday, January 1,
4713 BC, 12:00 noon, Greenwich
Mean Time.
And of course, being
here in Nottingham,
that's our time zone.
We're in the same time zone
as the Greenwich meridian.
By that reckoning,
February 29, 2012
is Julian date 2455987.
Yes.
Got it right.
You can add a decimal place
after that date which records
purely the decimal fraction of
the day that's gone by, but
one Julian date is
equal to one day.
So if you hear a Julian date
that ends with a 0.5, that
means half a day has passed in
addition to the full day that
it's counting.
Yes, this is going to sound
familiar to a lot of people,
because of course in the Star
Trek universe, you often hear
"Captain's log, stardate
2455.73," which is a similar
kind of concept.
But the Star Trek writers and
producers deliberately didn't
make it an official, fast and
fixed rule as to what a
stardate meant, so that they
could factor in all the
different concepts like speed of
travel, and different parts
the galaxy, and that
sort of thing.
So stardate is not the
same as Julian date.
So normally, I would probably
record the date of an
observation as April 3, 2010,
something like that, because
the work I do is not
particularly time-critical.
However, if you're recording
something like a gamma ray
burst or a periodic event like
the transit of a planet, then
a Julian date would be given
to a very high precision.
So having just said that I don't
use Julian dates very
often, here is a paper that I
wrote where I did use it.
So here, I made a plot with
Julian date, but I've
subtracted all of the large
part of the number just to
leave the cumulative number
of days here.
And so you can easily see that
we've gone from 545 to 560,
which is 15 days, and that's a
lot easier than saying we've
gone from January
25 to February
whatever in that reckoning.
See, I can't even do
it in my head.
So a leap second is the same
kind of concept in the idea
that it's correcting our
calendars to make things match
up, but it's not related to
the leap year at all.
It's purely adjusting for the
variable rotation of the Earth
to make a day last a day.